Дякую шановні мої дорогі освітяни за те
що ми за 30 років створили націю
нескорених
це саме освіта
А це покоління яке і надалі буде
відновлювати
важко говорити те що пережив Херсон
херсонщина Я думаю що сюди дойдеш і
допомога і всім
держава Україна в нас ви їх не забуває
не кидає для школ буде разом з фундацією
Parimatch foundation Ми даємо спортивне
обладнання яке сьогодні в кожній школі
потрібно ми в ліцеї були там дивились
все інше
підручники українські підручники не ті
які повиставляли там якісь
в недолугий Да в недолугий обгорці
дитинство в пілотці Слухайте ну я
подивлюсь ми будуємо світ цивілізований
щоб в XXI столітті це жінки плакали діти
ховались бобосховищах низький уклін всім
вам дорогі мої освітяни низькі уклін і
е-е все одно Україна відбудеться і е-е
відбудується навіть зараз онлайн але за
українськими освітніми стандартами
навіть онлайн але все одно разом і
говоримо про те що держава відбулася і
відводиться Слава Україні
сфери освіти за ініціативу та
наполегливість високий професіоналізм
сумлінне виконання службових обов'язків
та малому і особистий внесок у розвиток
сфери освіти науки України нагородити
подякую Міністерства освіти і науки
України білік Галину Володимирівну
чому уряду всієї держави коли ми
отримали заробітну плату ви тільки що
сказали ви нас не кинули це не гроші ти
а ми морально ми відчували що ми нужні я
знаю ви правильно сказали Ми віримо що
їх зараз знаєте це теж це кажу не я це
казала каже моє серце
аби коли отримували коли бачили ми
розуміли що Віру нашу нельзя затоптати
затоптати і ми знали що ви прийдете буде
деокупація обов'язково
херсонщина була є і буде Україна і
подивитися як горять наші душі як горять
наші очі це світло
світле Миру воно загасить і Україна
ніколи не буде в темряві Слава Україні